Donald Trump vuelve al circo electoral.
Y no solo vuelve, sino que el expresidente
Trump está desatado: Sigue con la teoría
del fraude electoral en 2020 y al mejor estilo
golpista ha llegado a pedir que no se acate la
Constitución de los Estados Unidos de América.
(¿Arrojamos los Resultados de las Elecciones
Presidenciales de 2020 y declaramos al GANADOR
JUSTO, o celebramos una NUEVA ELECCIÓN? Un
Fraude Masivo de este tipo y magnitud
admite la rescisión de todas las normas,
reglamentos y artículos, incluso los que se
encuentran en la Constitución. Donald Trump)
A Donald Trump le da absolutamente igual que
los tribunales y las investigaciones formales
tiraran por tierra su teoría del fraude.
El expresidente parece querer situarse
por encima de las normas, las
leyes y la propia Constitución.
Si estas no sirven a sus intereses
entonces no sirven para nada.
(Donald Trump cree que debemos poner fin a
“todas las normas, reglamentos y artículos,
incluso los que se encuentran en
la Constitución” para revocar las
elecciones de 2020. Esa fue su opinión el 6 de
enero y sigue siendo su opinión hoy. Ninguna
persona honesta puede negar ahora que Trump
es un enemigo de la Constitución. Liz Cheney)
(La Constitución es más importante que cualquier
Presidente. Fin de la historia. Elon Musk)
Hubo un tiempo en el que se justificaba
este comportamiento , sus insultos y
las constantes mentiras aludiendo a que, bueno,
que en última instancia todo esto era parte
del show. Una forma de espolear a las masas
y destacar un discurso político sin miedo
y sometimiento a lo políticamente correcto.
podemos encontrar con noticias como esta:
N1(Trump expresa su apoyo a los
asaltantes del Capitolio mientras
continúa abrazando a grupos extremistas. CNN)
El expresidente está diciendo que la gente que
participó en el asalto al Capitolio fue tratada de
forma injusta, dice que su campaña está apoyando
a algunos de los principales acusados e, incluso,
ha prometido indultos si regresa a la Casa Blanca.
Y, ojo, que puede querer convertir
ese fatídico 6 de enero en uno de
los pilares de su campaña. Sería una
forma de mantener su denuncia contra el
sistema al mismo tiempo que se crea su
propio escudo de fanáticos. Activistas
muy radicalizados que pueden jugar un peso
importante en las primarias republicanas.
Esto explicaría también por qué el expresidente
comenzó su nueva campaña política cenando con el
rapero antisemita Kanye West y con Nick Fuentes,
un conocido neonazi que estuvo en el mitin de
Trump previo al asalto al capitolio. Cuánto más
radicalizadas estén sus bases mejor que mejor.
Trump ha contribuido a normalizar comportamientos
que en cualquier otro momento hubieran resultado
inadmisibles y eso ha sido mala para todos.
Sin embargo, un momento, nuestra
intención no es hacer un juicio
sobre el expresidente sino ver por qué
en esta ocasión las cosas pueden ser
totalmente diferentes. Trump puede tener
muy complicado hacerse con las primarias.
El expresidente está perdiendo apoyos a
toda velocidad y de momento ni siquiera
es el gran favorito entre
los votantes republicanos.
¿Será que la estrella de
Donald Trump se está apagando?
¡Atentos!
Pero antes, antes dejadme hablaros de internet.
Como ya sabéis internet está lleno de hackers
y de páginas que nos meten cookies por todos los
lados por no hablar de cada vez más restricciones
geográficas. ¿Queréis poder ver contenido de
cualquier país sin ningún tipo de bloqueo y
además navegar por internet con seguridad? Pues
no lo penséis más, usad una VPN como Surfshark
VPN. Creedme, el tema de la ciberseguridad se
lo toman muy en serio. De hecho, Surfshark es
la primera VPN comercial que puede presumir de
tener servidores en más de 100 países distintos.
Pero no solo eso, Surfshark tiene una
herramienta que se llama cleanweb que
bloquea todos esos popups de propaganda
peligrosos, y por si todo esto fuera poco,
con una misma cuenta podrás registrar todos
los dispositivos que quieras. Por ejemplo,
¿quieres navegar con seguridad desde tu
SmartTV, desde tu tablet, tu telefono,
tu ordenador? Pues puedes meter todos
ellos en una misma cuenta de Surfshark.
Y lo mejor de todo: tienen una oferta
muy especial de Navidad para toda la
comunidad de VisualPolitik, ahora
mismo usando el código “POLITIK”
acabado en “K” podréis disfrutar de
un 85% de descuento y 3 meses gratis.
Y ahora, continuemos con nuestro video de hoy!
T1(¿EL OCASO DE TRUMP?)
La carrera política como líder republicano
de Donald Trump no comenzó aquel 16 de junio
de 2015 cuando Trump anunció por primera vez
su candidatura a las primarias republicanas.
Concretamente el 19 de noviembre de 2012,
pocos días después de que Barack Obama
derrotará a Mitt Romney Trump registró
como marca ese conocido lema que dice
Make America Great Again.
Un lema electoral con el que logró
convertirse contra todo pronóstico
en el cuadragésimo quinto presidente
de los Estados Unidos de América.
Gracias a una enorme carambola
electoral que le permitió hacerse
con los estados habitualmente
demócratas de Pennsylvania,
Michigan y Wisconsin por un puñado de votos.
Fue una victoria por la mínima, pero ganó.
En aquel momento Trump parecía
capaz de lograr lo imposible.
Hoy, sin embargo, las cosas
son completamente distintas.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Podemos destacar 3 claves
por las que Trump tendrá mucho más difícil
volver a repetir no ya como presidente,
sino incluso como candidato republicano.
Y es que hoy el trumpismo se
enfrenta a noticias como esta:
(7 de diciembre de 2022: Los
demócratas amplían la mayoría
del Senado después de ganar la
segunda vuelta de Georgia.FT)
Georgia tradicionalmente ha sido
un feudo republicano. Sin embargo,
Biden lo ganó contra todo pronóstico en
2020 y ahora en las elecciones de mitad
de mandato los demócratas también
han ganado la carrera al senado.
En la segunda vuelta que se celebra en este estado
cuando un candidato no supera el 50% de los votos,
el demócrata  Raphael
Warnock derrotó a Herschel Walker,
un candidato pro-Trump. Esto supuso
una gran victoria política para
la Administración Biden y un duro
varapalo para la campaña de Trump.
Y es que, veréis, Walker ha sido el único
candidato republicano en las elecciones de
2022 en no lograr la victoria. Las otras
8 elecciones con circunscripción estatal,
incluyendo la del gobernador, la del secretario
del estado y el fiscal general fueron ganadas
cómodamente por los republicanos. Es
decir, que Walker fue la excepción.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué diantres diferenció a
Walker del resto de candidatos republicanos?
Pues entre otras cosas que Walker era el único
candidato trumpista. De hecho, el gobernador Brian
Kemp se enfrentó al expresidente al defender
que las elecciones del 2020 fueron limpias.
C2.2(30 de diciembre de 2020: Brian
Kemp debe dimitir de su cargo. Es
un obstruccionista que se niega a
admitir que he ganado en Georgia,
¡por mucho! También ganamos otros estados
bisagra. - Donald Trump en Twitter
Claro que no se trata sólo de Georgia.
Las elecciones de mitad de mandato han
supuesto una dolorosa derrota para Trump.
(Tal y como podéis ver en pantalla
de los 16 candidatos a Senador,
Gobernador y Secretario de Estado que
formaban parte del núcleo trumpista en
los estados en disputa que fueron ganados
por Biden y que por tanto son vitales para
las aspiraciones republicanas en 2024,
tan solo 2 consiguieron la victoria.
Y esto es tan sólo un pequeño ejemplo del mal
desempeño republicano en unas elecciones de mitad
de mandato que a priori les eran favorables.)
De hecho, los republicanos esperaban una gran
ola de victorias que…. sin embargo no
se produjo. Los demócratas ampliaron
su influencia en el Senado y prácticamente
empataron en la Cámara de Representantes.
Los resultados fueron claros: los
candidatos colocados por Trump, muchos
de ellos extremistas que repiten las consignas
del expresidente tuvieron un desempeño malísimo.
Las derrotas de los candidatos pro-Trump al Senado
Blake Masters en Arizona, Adam Laxalt en Nevada,
Mehmet Oz en Pensil✓vania y Herschel Walker
en Georgia fueron particularmente dolorosas.
Y esto nos lleva directamente a la
primera clave de por qué esta vez
las cosas pueden ser diferentes
para el expresidente. Puede que
te sorprenda pero Trump se ha convertido
en toda una máquina de perder elecciones.
Ganó por la mínima en 2016, perdió en
2018, en 2020 y, otra vez, en 2022.
C3("Si dejamos a Trump, empezaremos a ganar las
elecciones. Si nos quedamos con Trump, seguiremos
perdiendo las elecciones. Así es como lo
veo", Paul Ryan, político republicano,
exPresidente de la Cámara de Representantes
y candidato a la Vicepresidencia en 2016)
C4"Sé que mucha gente de nuestro partido adora
al ex presidente. Pero él es, podemos decir,
el beso de la muerte para los que quieran ganar
unas elecciones generales. Y en algún momento,
tendremos que seguir adelante
y buscar nuevos líderes que nos
lleven a la victoria" Mitt Romney,
Senador republicano por Utah).
Cuando en 2015 Trump anunció su candidatura
el partido venía de lograr una enorme ola
republicana que los había llevado a conseguir
54 senadores, 247 escaños en la Cámara de
Representantes y 31 gobernadores. Hoy
están mucho peor en todos los frentes.
Puede que te sorprenda, pero la era de Trump se
ha saldado con mucho menos poder para
los Republicanos. Que el expresidente
fuera uno de los pocos presidentes en no
lograr la reelección no fue algo casual.
De hecho hablamos de un candidato relativamente
impopular. En todas las encuestas su grado de
desaprobación supera de media el 55%. Fijaos.
Y ya ni siquiera es el candidato favorito para
los republicanos. ¿Espera, cómo? Sí, sí,.. Fijaos.
(Una nueva encuesta encuentra que Ron DeSantis
tiene una ventaja de 7 puntos sobre Trump en
las primarias presidenciales de 2024. NYPost)
Claro que esta no es la única clave que explica
por qué esta campaña se le puede
complicar y mucho al expresidente.
El segundo motivo tiene que ver con
que vaya totalmente por libre. Hecho
que entre las filas republicanas está
empezando a despertar cierta preocupación
Por ejemplo, justo antes de las
elecciones de mitad de mandato,
Trump puso en marcha una campaña contra una de
las grandes estrellas que hoy tiene el Partido
Repúblicano: Hablamos, por supuesto,
del gobernador de Florida Ron DeSantis.
Un viejo aliado que sin embargo ahora ha
cosechado una gran victoria en Florida y
empieza a ser relativamente popular en
todo el país. Pues bien, Trump viéndole
las orejas al lobo le ha puesto directamente
en su diana. Y eso explica noticias como esta:
(Trump se lanza a la guerra contra DeSantis)
Y no se trata de un caso aislado. Para nada.
Cada vez que un líder republicano no le
hace el juego, Trump le pone en su diana
cueste lo que cueste y suponga
lo que suponga para el partido.
El caso del gobernador de Virginia Glenn
Youngkin o lo que está ocurriendo en
Arizona son también buenos ejemplos.
En este último caso y de la mano de
organizaciones como la Turning Point USA el
trumpismo ha intentado purgar a todos los
moderados y a todos los candidatos
de la vieja guardia republicana.
En su lugar están poniendo a candidatos
mucho más exaltados, radicales y fieles
a Trump… que entre otras cosas niegan
que Estados Unidos sea una democracia.
Hablamos de un grupo incontrolable que
electoralmente también son un desastre.
El caso es que Trump va por libre y parece
querer hacer del Partido Republicano una
organización sumisa a su pleno servicio. Como os
podéis imaginar está generando mucha inquietud
dentro del ala no trumpista del partido
que sigue siendo claramente mayoritaria.
Pero aún no hemos terminado.
La tercera clave tiene que ver con
todos los procesos judiciales a los
que se enfrenta el expresidente.
Y, ojo, porque no se trata de que
tenga algún que otro problema. No, a Trump los
problemas judiciales le llegan hasta el cuello.
Desde el robo de documentos
secretos sobre armas nucleares,
hasta su participación en el asalto al
Capitolio o problemas fiscales de todo
tipo. Ni siquiera es improbable que Trump
termine en el banquillo de los acusados.
De momento, a los pocos días de
presentar su candidatura ocurrió esto:
N5(6 de diciembre de 2022: La
organización Trump se declaró
culpable de fraude fiscal penal
en el juicio de Nueva York. WSJ)
Claro que esto es solo la punta del Iceberg.
Pues bien, estas son las 3 claves que
hacen que esta vez el expresidente no
parta con ninguna aureola de éxito. Y
eso, por supuesto, tiene consecuencias.
Por ejemplo, cada vez son más y más
los republicanos que abogan por pasar
página. Y esto ocurre incluso entre
algunas conocidas figuras trumpistas.
C5("Un verdadero líder entiende cuándo se ha
convertido en un pasivo. Un verdadero líder
entiende que es hora de salir del escenario, y
los votantes nos han dado ese mensaje muy claro".
Winsome Sears, Vicegobernadora de Virginia)
Su propio Vicepresidente que puso mucha distancia
de por medio tras el asalto al Capitolio
ya ha dejado claro que no apoyará a Trump.
N6(Pence sobre si votaría por Trump
en 2024: "Podría haber alguien más a
quien preferiría más". CNN)
Y, ojo que este rechazo incluye
también a importantes donantes del partido.
N7(Schwarzman de Blackstone dice que no apoyará
la candidatura presidencial de Donald Trump. FT)
C6("Es hora de que el Partido Republicano
recurra a una nueva generación de líderes
y tengo la intención de apoyar a uno de
ellos en las primarias presidenciales".
Stephen Schwarzman, fundador de Blackstone)
N8(El megadonante del Partido Republicano Ken
Griffin, que puso 60 millones de dólares para
las campañas republicanas del actual ciclo,
llamó a Trump '3 veces perdedor'
y dijo que no debería postularse
para presidente. Business Insider)
Pero no solo hablamos de políticos
y donantes. Sino también de los
propios medios de comunicación.
Medios que tanto han apoyado
a Trump como la Fox o el New
York Post ya están poniendo tierra de por medio.
Y. ¿sabéis qué? Creo que este es uno
de esos momentos en los que una imagen
vale más que mil palabras. Así es como el
NY Post ha comenzando a tratar a Trump:
Y sobre todo así es como está empezando
a considerar sus alternativas.
Ron deSantis, el gobernador de Florida se está
convirtiendo en la nueva gran estrella del
Partido Republicano. Y si finalmente decidiera
dar el paso de presentarse a las primeras,
esto podría suponer un tremendo mazazo, otro
más, para las aspiraciones de Donald Trump.
¿Por qué? Pues… Veámoslo.
T2(¿EL VERDUGO DE TRUMP?)
Procedente de una familia de clase media,
Ron DeSantis estudió en Yale y en Harvard,
sirvió en el ejército, fue abogado
militar, estuvo desplegado en Irak,
ha sido Congresista y ahora en su reelección
como gobernador de Florida ha arrasado.
DeSantis se hizo con casi el 60% de los votos
en un estado que hasta ahora era considerado
competitivo para los demócratas. Eso ya no será
así. DeSantis cosechó incluso una ventaja de 15
puntos entre los votantes hispanos lo que le
valió ganar hasta en el Condado de Miami-Dade,
la primera vez que un republicano lo
consigue en las últimas dos décadas.
Sobre el gobernador de Florida y
sus posiciones políticas haremos
un vídeo específico muy pronto
aquí en VisualPolitik, así que,
ya sabéis, no olvidéis suscribiros
si es que aún no lo habéis hecho ya.
De momento lo que nos importa es que
hablamos de un tipo muy conservador
que según las encuestas ya es el preferido
por los votantes republicanos. Y no solo
eso. Mientras que a nivel nacional Biden le
saca 10 puntos a Trump, empata con DeSantis.
Si finalmente diera el paso de presentarse a
las primarias republicanas ese podría llegar
a suponer el final de las aspiraciones de Trump.
Claro que todavía no está claro que se presente.
Pero como os he dicho de todo eso y
más hablaremos en un próximo vídeo.
De momento turno para ti: ¿Crees que
Trump será el candidato republicano
en 2024? ¿Crees que es una buena
idea que se presente o por contra
debería hacer de una vez por todas a
un lado? ¿Qué opinión tienes de Trump?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like.
Muchas gracias una vez más por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.